I'm finding this out with my kids who my
son my son is 11 my daughter's 13 that
already I'm noticing there's like a
generation gap and it's hard for me to
relate to how their lives are compared
to what my life was like when I was
their age absolutely and I used to like
almost cringe when I heard the like when
I was growing up stories the night when
I when I used to hear that when I was a
kid I think like you know now I'm doing
it well
take for instance we'd write like we
live now in the recreational marijuana
era where every day a new state you know
either has it medicinal or recreational
like Nevada for instance has it now so
you can go to a state and Gamble and get
a prostitute and smoke weed and watch
the Raiders play all in a weekend yeah
three out of four is not bad
but so but then I was thinking like he's
gonna come up in this era and then I'm
gonna be like you know when I was your
age to get weed I almost died yeah and
he'll be like why was 7-eleven on fire
no I used to get in cars with strangers
yeah it'd be like where are we going
they'd be like chill out okay and then
we would do drive to other counties and
I would if you're like well what kind of
weight were you moving twenty dollars
worth of marijuana I would drive three
hour round trips and knock on dudes
trailer park doors and that was like for
me just to get a joint you know and
right they would tell me like watch this
watch the place while I'm gone if
anybody comes to hear you shoot him I'm
like okay it's a little different than
like my stomach hurts can I get a
prescription yeah
you